Hi there!
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer for Discovery
News, and I wanted to address that kid question
all parents dread: Where do babies come from?
Well, I don’t HAVE to answer to that as
I’m neither a parent or a biologist, but
I CAN answer where baby PLANETS come from.
Planetary formation theories kind of make
logical sense.
Starting with a nebula, containing hydrogen
and dust, a clump may form in this stellar
nursery that undergoes gravitational collapse.
Our sun was spawned inside such a cloud, around
4.6 billion years ago, forcing a chain reaction
that sparked fusion, forming the solar core.
While our young sun violently burned, pulling
in more and more material as it bulked up,
a dusty disk became compressed, spinning about
the young star’s axis of rotation.
As time went on, this disk -- known as a proto-planetary
disk -- cooled and small dust grains started
to clump together.
Over hundreds of millions of years, these
dusty clumps became bigger and bigger, exerting
their growing gravitational pull attracting
even more dust.
These clumps attached to more clumps, forming
small rocky objects called asteroids.
Asteroids collided, clumped and grew and eventually
formed protoplanets -- otherwise known as
baby planets!
These protoplanets kept growing, eventually
settling into their current stable orbits
as the solar system’s planets.
So, Earth started out as part of a spinning
disk, then a clump of dust, then a bigger
clump of rocks, followed by a protoplanet
and finally the planet we know and love today.
This is all well and good in theory, but it
has been hard for astronomers to observe these
processes around other young stars.
But that was until the European Southern Observatory’s
Atacama Large Millimeter/submillimeter Array,
also known as ALMA, spied the protoplanetary
disk surrounding the star “HL Tauri” in
2014.
At the time this image was called “revolutionary”
by astronomers as it was the clearest view
yet of tracks or gaps carved out by baby planets
around a VERY young star only one million
years old.
But these gaps didn’t necessarily prove
they were formed by unseen protoplanets; it
was only indirect evidence of them gravitationally
vacuuming up the dusty debris.
So there is a chance these tracks could just
be empty regions.
But if they aren’t empty regions, this would
mean it was the first evidence of a young
star birthing baby planets.
Now, astronomers using the Very Large Array
(VLA) in New Mexico, have viewed the same
star at longer radio wavelengths and has directly
seen material clumping inside one of those
gaps.
And they’ve estimated that the clump, composed
of 1 centimeter wide grains, weighs in at
between 3 to 8 times the mass of Earth, which
gives us a hint at how big the future planet
might be.
That fuzzy blob is basically the gravitational
agglomeration of small pebbles getting corralled
to form larger and larger clumps that will
go on to form a planet.
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is where baby
planets come from!
There is, however, some weirdness.
In another study published earlier this month,
dying stars may ALSO be able to give birth
to planets.
Yeah, dying stars... giving birth to planets
[pause]
Using the ESO’s Very Large Telescope Interferometer
(or VLTI), also located in the Atacama Desert
in Chile, a dusty disk produced by a sun-like
star was also imaged.
However, this is no young star -- it is a
dying star that has run out of fuel and puffed
up into a red giant and is sporting a protoplanetary-like
disk.
Yep, it looks like even dying stars could
produce baby planets like their young star
cousins.
For more of the cool science behind why stuff
in the universe is always spinning, check
out Trace’s recent spacey DNews video
Do you have any other awkward space questions
you need answers to?
Let us know in the comments, and don’t forget
to like this video and subscribe for a new
episode of DNews every day.